سمحت لي سؤال انا في هالاطار بالامكان
الاخ عبد الرحمن وقتها لما حددت الحادث
اعتقد كان وقت مدارس
اكيد انه رجع بعد ايام للمدرسه كيف كان
استيعاب زملائه في تلك الحقبه وكيف ردود
افعالهم وكيف كانوا يدورون الحوار خاصه
انه عبد الرحمن فقد يعني والده هل كان في
ادراك ان هناك تنظيم هناك ارهاب ايضا
البيئه التعليميه وقتها
يعني في المدرسه في المدرسه ايش الحكي
بالضبط وكيف كيف كيف
اتساءلوا كيف تناقشوا حوله فعلا
والله للامانه
اغلب الجيل الحالي
اللي ما عاش قصه
هو وقتها وقت التفجيره كان صغير في السن
فممكن يكون ما هو بمستوعب للدرجه المطلوبه
لكن بالنسبه لي انا واللي حولي احنا عشنا
قصه
فاضطرينا نستوعب اضطرينا نقرا
يعني مداركنا توسعت في الموضوع هذا
وبعدين في هذاك الوقت الناس يمكن حصل
التفجيرهم صغار فاكبروا وينسون
بما انها توقفت التفجيرات لكن
صاحب الالم صاحب الالم ما يقدر ما ينسى
مستحيل ينسى وادراكه اكبر في الموضوع
وبالنسبه
للمدرسه اتوقع انه يعني في المدرسه عندي
كانوا مدركين لان برضو كان عندهم في صله
مع شخص
والمدرسه في ذاك الوقت كانت تتكلم على
هالموضوع انه حصل تفجير وتوفى والد زميلكم
وكذا وكذا وكذا وكذا وكذا وكذا فصار في
ادراك اكثر يمكن بالنسبه لهم
لكن عموما الجيل الحالي
يعني افكار متوسعه اكثر يقدر يدرك بسهوله
يقدر يتعلم بسهوله
فالاغلب عارف وش الصح وش الغلط
الاغلبيه الجيل الحالي بس هو سؤال انا
وحمود وربما بعض المشاهدين من واقع جلساتك
مثلا
جلسات مع الزملاء مع رحله كشته او في
العمل او كذا او في السوشيال ميديا حاسس
انهم مستوعبين وش اللي صار هذاك الوقت هذا
السؤال يعني انه تنظيم دولي وانه كان هدفه
كذا وانه رفع شعار اخرجوا المشركين من
جزيره العرب عشان يضرب العلاقه السعوديه
الامريكيه
لها ضلع في الموضوع ذا عرفت قصدي يعني
التفاصيل هذه في ناس لكن ما هو بكلهم
يعني انا زي ما قلت لك الناس اللي حولي
مدركه
لكن حسب انا قراءتي في
وسائل التواصل وهكذا كثير ناس ما هي مدركه